Did you please offer advice for
individuals with high intelligence but
low extroversion and low agreeableness
and making and maintaining social
connections and friendships?
Well,
I would,
that's Roger,
Roger.
I would say
make a plan.
Again,
spend some time on it weekly.
Go to things like meetups.
There's a site called meetup.com that's
a good place to meet people.
Do whatever you have to do.
Meet people,
take a course,
strike up a conversation,
you know,
and,
and ask questions and listen that,
that's particularly good.
If you're low in agreeableness,
um,
people really like to be listened to.
You know,
you don't want to pester them with
questions too badly,
but you can get an awful long ways by
listening to people and asking them
questions.
It's a,
people hardly ever get listened to and
they're so damn help,
happy when you do it,
that,
um,
that they're likely to open themselves
up to you very,
very rapidly.
So get them talking.
And when they say something,
you don't quite catch your understand,
ask them about it and,
and that can help you move forward.
But put some time into it.
Like you need to be going out at least
once a week,
um,
and find some social places that you can
go to regularly.
That's another thing you can do,
you know,
was the pick a couple of hangouts,
like a local bar or something like that
or whatever.
But go there regularly and say hi to the
people who own it and run it.
Then,
you know,
eventually you'll be irregular and then
you can start to meet people by doing
that.
But,
you know,
it might take you two or three years to
get good at it.
Um,
I've seen people go to go from being
afraid to strike up a two to have a
conversation with a friend in a,
in a coffee shop,
you know,
like have a panic attack.
Thinking about that to actually doing
stand up comedy.
So you can really move yourself along
ways if you,
if you make a long time plan.